プロップスのバリデーションについてもう少し詳細に説明したいと思います
まずバリデーション付きのプロップスを複数書く場合は
こんな風にプロパティをつなげて書けばOKです
名前は違うものにする必要があるんですけれども
こんな風につなげて書くことで複数のプロップスを定義することができます
またここのタイプのところは実は配列を使って複数指定することもできまして
この場合はナンバーとストリング型のどちらかであればOKという意味になります
ちなみにここの型は他にどんなものがあるのかっていうと
例えばブーリアン 審議値ですねとか
アレイ 配列 オブジェクト あと関数だったりとか
ちょっと高度な内容になるんですけれども
シンボルとか あと日付のデイトとか
他にも自分でクラスとかを作って
それをですね 指定することができたりもします
その場合はそのクラスのインスタンスであればOKというような動きになります
ちょっと一度消しておきますね
あと実はこのデフォルトの値には
普通の値じゃなくて関数を指定することもできます
この時はタイプがファンクションの時だけは普通の関数として扱われるんですけれども
それ以外の時はデフォルトの値が使われる時に
この関数がすぐに実行されて
その返り値がデフォルトの値になるようになっていますので
例えばですけれども
この親のフォというプロプスを消すと
ちゃんとデフォルトの100という値が指定されているのがわかると思います
こういう関数を使った指定の仕方は
普通はですね使う必要はないんですけれども
ちょっとJavaScriptの制約上
デフォルトの値がオブジェクトもしくは配列の時だけは
必ずですねこの関数を使った指定の仕方を行う必要があります
なのでこんな風にですね
直接デフォルトの値を指定することは
それがオブジェクトか配列であればできません
オブジェクトと配列の時は必ず関数を作って
その返り値で指定するという方法を取る必要があります
のでここだけですねややこしいんですけれども注意してください
もちろん普通の値の場合100とかそういうものはですね
普通に関数を使わなくてもOKです
配列とオブジェクトの時だけ関数ですね
またデフォルトの値自体が設定されていない時は
つまりデフォルトプロパティのデフォルトの値は
アンディファインドになると言いましたよね
なのでアンディファインドとすると
トゥルト出るのが分かると思うんですけれども
実はタイプをブーリアンにした時だけは
アンディファインドになりません
今フォルスと出ていると思うんですけれども
アンディファインドじゃないんですね
何になるかというと
フォルスになります
今これでトゥルト出ていると思うんですけれども
若干ちょっとトゥルトがフォルスとか
やこしいと思うんですけれども
要はフォーに直接フォルスが入っているということですね
なのでこんな風に書いた場合は
ちゃんとフォルスと出ているのが分かると思います
なのでタイプがブーリアンの時だけは
デフォルトのデフォルトの値がフォルスになっているということです
ちなみにリンターはタイプがブーリアンの時だけは
リクワイヤーでデフォルトがなかったとしてもですね
こんな風に警告を出さなかったりします
Cマコンソールももちろん出ません
なのでタイプブーリアンだけをですね
書いても問題なかったりします
またタイプがブーリアンのプロップスを
親のコンポーネントで
性的にVバインドとかを使わずに指定するときは
実はHTMLのブーリアン属性のように指定することができまして
こんな風に値を指定せずに
単純にフーという属性名を書くだけでも
これはトゥルーの値を指定したのと同じ意味になります
なので今こんな風にトゥルーと出ているのが分かると思います
でなかった場合はフォルスが設定されるわけですね
なので性的にデータを指定する場合は
こんな風に指定することもできるということを知っておいてください
ただしもちろんVバインドで動的にデータを指定する場合は
ちゃんと値を書く必要がありますし
トゥルーと書いたらトゥルーになって
フォルスと書いたらフォルスが渡るという風になっていますので
Vバインドを使うときは普通のプロップスと同じです
あくまでも性的に指定するときだけですね
こんな風に値を指定しなくても
トゥルーの値を渡すことができるということです
であとこのプロップスのところは
実はもう一つバリデータというメソッドを書くこともできまして
これは返り値でフォルスを返すと警告が出るようになっています
でトゥルーを返すと警告が出なくなるというものになります
またこのバリデータでは
引数に実際に親から渡される値
例えばVバインドをつけてカウントとすると
0とかそういうものですね
が入るようになっています
もしくはなかったらデフォルトの値が入るようになっているんですね
なので例えばですけれども
渡された値が0
もしくは1のときはOK
それ以外はダメみたいなですね
詳細なバリデーションを書くことが
このバリデーターメソッドを使うことで可能になります
のでこれでですね見てみると
ちょっと今タイプがですねプーリアになっているので
ナンバーとしておきますね
そうするとカウントが0と1のときは何も警告は出ませんが
カウントが2より上になると
こんな風に警告が出ると
こういう風になります
ちなみに今ちょっと
リンターがリクワイヤードかデフォルトがないので
色いな見せを出してるんですけれども
ちょっとリクワイヤードトゥルーとしておきますね
またJavaScriptの書き方の話なんですけれども
メソッドに関してはこんな風に省略して書くことができますので
こんな風にしておきますね
ぜひですねこのバリデータも
なくてもですね
特にリンターは傾向を出したりはしないんですけれども
詳細なバリデーションの設定ができますので
ぜひ活用するようにしてみてください
あとちなみになんですけれども
このディファインプロップスの引数の中では
一切それよりも外部のデータを使うことはできません
ので例えばですけれども
何でもいいんですけれども
例えばisRequiredとして
trueとしてこれを設定するみたいなことはできません
必ずですね
このディファインプロップスの引数の中だけで
完結している必要があります
外部のデータとかにアクセスすることはできません
のでそこだけ注意してください
では次はプロップスの命名規則についてを
軽く紹介したいと思います